[Music]
joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author a national security
expert and founder of act for America
brigitte gabriel welcome to the Reuben
report thank you I'm so delighted to be
with you I'm delighted to be with you
know what a nod or what an honor do you
know that just the two of us sitting
down before we even say anything is
going to trigger a lot of people there's
going to be some outrage people just
because we're sitting here before we hey
you know I think yes you can't cause
problems while you go through life
you're not doing something right
indeed so you have caused some problems
for some people I find you to be on the
right side of most stuff and someone
that's doing it with a bit of a sense of
humor and and attacking the right people
and we have some enemies in common who
we'll get to shortly but first let's
just start with your story you grew up
in Lebanon people don't know much about
Lebanon tell me a little bit and now
they don't and this is why I am so
passionate about this issue because
terrorism affected my life personally in
Lebanon you know people ask me all the
time Brigitte where does this passion
comes from and I tell them because
terrorism changed my life I was born
into a country Lebanon that used to be
majority Christian country when I was a
child we were open minded we were fair
we were tolerant we were multicultural
we prided ourselves in our
multiculturalism we had open border
policy be welcome to everyone into our
country because we wanted to share with
them the westernization which we had
created in the heart of the Middle East
Mullens used to send their children to
study in our universities they graduated
and worked in our economy because we had
built the best economy in the Middle
East did they call Beru Beirut was the
Paris of the Middle East Paris of the
Middle East
exactly unfortunately all that began to
change as the Muslims became the
majority and the Christians became the
minority and that's when my life changed
I remember we used to go to Beirut for
Christmas to visit with the rest of my
family I lived in the south with my
parents and I would and we stopped going
and I would ask my father why we're not
going to the family for Christmas or
Easter and he would tell me well we
decided to stay home this year
I couldn't understand you know why we
decided to stay home you have to
understand that was an only child to an
elderly couple it was very boring and I
don't I later learned that the reason
why we stayed home is because the
radical Islamist and Palestinians would
set up a fly-by-night checkpoint and
would stop cars traveling and they would
ask people for their IDs when they would
stop them and in Lebanon our religion is
written on our national ID you are
either a Christian a Muslim or a Jew so
when they find out that you are a
Christian they would get everybody out
of their car and shoot them in cold
blood it became known as identity
killing at the time Thomas Friedman
talks about it in his book from Beirut
to Jerusalem yeah that changed our life
but really the turning point was in 1975
when radical Islam is to blow up my home
bringing it down burning me under the
rubble wounded as they fell along about
ten or ten years old I ended up in a
hospital for two and a half months and
as I laid in a hospital bed going from
surgery one surgery to another I would
ask my father why did they do this to us
and my father would tell me because we
are Christians the Muslims consider us
infidels and they want to kill us
so I learned since I was a 10 year old
little girl that I am wanted dead simply
because I was born into the Christian
faith yeah whether I practiced it or not
it was irrelevant than my enemy's eyes
yeah and that's why people in America
don't understand they think when people
say especially from the Middle East and
I'm a Christian or a Muslim in America
they think well I'm a Christian only if
I'm a practicing bible-thumper Holy
Roller to surf because now that makes me
a Christian right right well for us in
our region of the world whether you're
practicing or not you belong to the
Christian race or group and that's why
they want to kill you it doesn't matter
whether you practice your religion ours
right even though of course a religion
isn't even a race but you'reyou're
saying it that way to illustrate the
point that all right you're Debbie's
automatical rule yeah in other words if
your grandparents were Christians it
doesn't matter if you have been two
generation atheist you are a Christian
that's how your enemy looks at you Isis
al Qaeda all these terrorist
organizations all these
radical devout Islamists look at you
look at America as a Christian nation
not because we practice Christianity
look at you as a Christian whether you
practice Christianity or not is
irrelevant right your great great great
great great grandparents for either Jews
or Christian
therefore you belong to either one or
the OTO of that side right you could be
the biggest he's an atheist on the
planet that one adder he wouldn't like
you for that either but doesn't matter
you belong to that join infidel
so it's interesting I think in the in a
couple years that I've been doing the
show the only other person from Lebanon
I've had on is Professor GAD sat up in
Canada and he's Jewish and his story is
very similar to yours about when things
changed and his family having to get out
and his parents were kidnapped by PLO
terrorist they actually survived which
is sort of incredible and now he fights
for a lot of the same things you fight
for I'm curious though when when Islam
was was increasing in Lebanon because we
now see this in Europe and and partly
what's happening all over the world were
people talking about it was your family
like what were the moments that they
thought there's something culturally
happening here that that it's not the
same we were afraid I was a child I was
10 years old when the war started no but
I remember my parents trying to hide and
I remember hiding with my parents in the
basement
or trying to flee our neighborhood
before we lived permanently in the bomb
shelter yeah because you know I lived in
a bomb shelter underground for seven
years of my life from the age of ten
till the age of seventeen hiding to
survive but we went to a period of about
six months we would flee our home in the
middle of the night and run downtown to
hide at my cousin's home and we would
hide they had a basement or nobody could
get to it and we were afraid because we
knew that our Muslim neighbors were
turning against us people who we would
use to barbecue with the weekend before
where all of a sudden massacring us the
next weekend so everything changed so
fast and he didn't know how to eat it's
not that you didn't know who you can
trust because it enemy turned against
neighbor neighbor turned against
neighbor yeah once the call of Islam
once the call of jihad was declared
because everyone was immediately divided
into sects the Muslims was the call of
Islam was declared first
the Palestinians all the Muslims went to
the Palestinians and literally the army
split and they took their from the
military bases whoever drove a tank the
Muslims took it home with them literally
home and the Christians took whatever
weapons they can have in whatever tanks
to protect ourselves and this is how the
country became divided and that's when
we started realizing we were different
so in the midst of all this war you had
a really strange experience with some
Israelis that kind of changed your
feelings on things can you talk about
that / absolutely when I was a child
when the war broke out even when I was a
child going to school we were taught
that Israel is the enemy now at my home
I was never taught aid because your
questions we don't preach hatred up plus
we have more things in common with the
Jews I mean we share the same Bible so
it's different but by the time I was a
child I'm a love and I was majority
Muslim so the anti-semitism the hatred
for Israel was rising especially with
the Palestinian issue especially with
the influx of Palestinians into Lebanon
it was what I heard on television what I
heard on the radio but when the war
started all of a sudden we were trapped
we ended up living in a bomb shelter and
I remember my father saying all the
world Christian nations are going to
come see what's happening to the
Christians and save the Christians
because that's when the Muslims started
massacring the Christians literally and
we thought America's going to come
Australia is going to come breathing is
going to come France is going to come
and nobody came
and finally few people from my town got
together and they said we've got to go
to the Israeli border and beg for help
we're not five kilometers from the
Israeli border and we knew if we go to
Israel a beg for help the Jews are not
going to slaughter us because we had
more shared values with them than we had
with the Moslems so a few people from my
town go to Israel and wave down an
Israeli Patrol in the middle of the
night and they say listen we are
surrounded by the Muslims and
Palestinians and majority of
Palestinians are Muslims who want to
slaughter us you either come in and help
us or they're going to be at your border
so Israel started coming in the middle
of the night and started bringing
ammunition to the military food for the
children because Muslims cut off also
supplies our towns and Israel would
bring literally bomb shelters to those
did not have bomb shelters blankets
everything and Israel would take
Christian men to Israel and teach them
how to fight because the Christians were
the educated ones and we learned very
quickly David that you can have all your
degrees professional degrees on your
wall your accounting degree your medical
degree your law degree none of that will
do you as they say impacts of
diddly-squat when you are faced with an
enemy bent on killing you in the name of
Allah yeah so Israel would take groups
of Christians trained them how to fight
and this is how we survived I remember
at the age of 13 we have been living in
the bomb shelter for three years and one
of our militia friends came by and he
said Brigitte I just want to tell you
that we heard a lot of chatter on the
radio and we're going to be attacked
tonight and he said I don't think we're
going to last
I think our town will fall and he said
if I don't see you tomorrow I wish you a
merciful death and he left and I
remember David at the age of 13 years
old putting on my Sunday best my Easter
dress because I wanted to look pretty
when I am dead because I knew that when
they come to slaughter me there would be
no one to bury me and I remember sobbing
and my mother combed my long black hair
down to my hips and side the white
ribbon in my hair as I begged her I
don't want to die I'm only 13 years old
please I don't want to die and there was
nothing my mother could say to me and we
sat on the corner of our bomb shelter
that night and my father said to me he
said listen we live the long life you
are a young child when they come to
slaughter us tonight you just run
towards Israel and you never look back
you'll create a commotion you just run
towards Israel thank God I do not have
to make that decision that night because
Vespa nights when Israel came in
physically into Lebanon and established
the security zone and set up artillery
bases around our town to protect us so
the Islamists will not be able to come
in and fly us and we went on living like
this until 1982 another five years until
Israel invaded Lebanon in 1982 and
Israel invaded Lebanon working with the
Christians in Lebanon
so the Christians take back their
democracy re-establish control of the
country and kick out the radical Islamic
element that has taken control of the
country at that time because by 1982 we
had 11 Islamic terrorist organizations
operating out of Lebanon including the
PLO yeah all right so let's pause there
because there's so much politics but
what's obviously shines through is your
personal story and it's so interesting
to me I find this when I talk to certain
guests who've lived through a lot you
talk about a bomb children it's almost
like oh I lived in a bomb shelter for
three years like it's just it is what it
is as opposed to it's impossible for me
to even fathom what that could be like
how much do you feel like your own story
here has sort of been hijacked I guess
that's sort of an operative word here
that for people like you and I on and
Yasmin Mohamed Lyon a couple weeks ago
people that have lived through some of
this stuff these stories really don't
get told anymore because they somehow
because you're using all the buzz words
when you say Muslim or this or that that
people are afraid to talk about this and
all you've done so far is tell your own
personal story alright and it's the
story that shapes my life and my outlook
I was robbed of my childhood people
asked me where does this passion come
from Bridgette I tell them you know how
Holocaust survivors walk around with
tattoos on their arms I walk around with
scars
I still have shrapnel in my bones this
is what I look at when I take a shower
every morning and I am reminded of what
happens when people turn a blind eye to
evil thinking it's not going to happen
to me
I am the and Frank who lived to tell
about it and I'm trying to warn the
world in my situation in my life living
with crawling under the bombs digging
out grass to eat
digging out dandelions to eat one of my
job if you want to call a job at the
bomb shelter we lived with my parents it
was only me and them and this hall six
feet underground no sunshine always in
the darkness mildew on the walls
literally white those who cover the wall
and we would sit there dirt floors
and my one of my jobs was breaking
chickpeas old dried chickpeas that my
mother would soak overnight and water
because he didn't have any food other
than whatever Caritas would bring a box
of food and I remember we they had bugs
in the chickpeas and my job was to break
the chickpea in half and with little
needle take the bugs out of what I'm on
the side of the dish so we can eat the
chickpeas I remember she I had long hair
and I remember as a child people see me
today and they think this glamorous lady
and they think oh wow what a wife you
know they don't realize what carved the
character of the person you see today I
remember as a child sleeping on the
floor on the dirt and getting lice in my
hair and I remember my mother putting
kerosene on my head
so it will kill the lines and combing my
hair and I remember closing my nose and
my eyes are burning and my mother would
say it's okay this will kill the life
and this became our life we went from as
a child as an only child to a successful
businessman with a live-in servant and
it show first to drive me to school was
sitting with my parents breaking
chickpeas with bugs digging out for
dandelions to eat and my mother coming
life out of my hair by killing it by
putting kerosene or Mesut or benzene on
my head we didn't have any medication I
don't drink alcohol people ask me all
the time oh why don't you drink it I
think that's a religious thing well the
bomb shelter because my father owned the
restaurant the bomb shelter was a
storage room for all the liquor and wine
because obviously Street underground its
temperature control yeah and we didn't
have any medication and we didn't have
any doctors to go to the hospital was
bombed out and we used alcohol as
medication so what I would be sick once
a month and I didn't have any pills or
any medication and and I would be an
extreme terrible pain and my father
would pour me a shot of whiskey Johnnie
Walker seven seven seven right oh honey
just drugged this will take your pain
away so in my mind as an adult I
associate alcohol with medicine so I
don't even drink anything it changes
your life
New Year's Eve took me 50 years to
figure out why I cry every New Year's
Eve why I feel other sadness coming to
me as people get so excited at midnight
and I could have put my finger on it
people would be so Juventud so excited
and I would look around that I would
always stare up and I learned the scars
of war growing up in a bomb shelter when
you don't have anything to smile about
or less about in your formative years
you don't know how to be happy those
wires that connect people excited and
learning how to be happy as you're
developing as your brain is developing
to know what is free is to be happy
happy happy that that exuberant joy
where people are just let loose and be
happy I don't have that I was robbed of
that so when I would watch people on New
Year's Eve being so happy that's when it
tipped me that I couldn't get that happy
and I didn't know why and I couldn't
even recognize it until I thought to be
50 years old so I started learning about
my background and what shaped me those
are the untold stories that people do
not want to bother hearing it's like
when you talk to Holocaust survivors
they they come here they're successful
they're brilliant the own greatness is
like Lebanese like like me yeah I I am
living the American dream I made
lemonade out of lemons like Holocaust
like many other cursed stories you hear
yeah and you don't hear the details
because people do not want to bother
hearing what shaped the person to become
the stroke person to be able to move
forward in life and become productive
and do great things in life and become
philanthropist and change the world and
make it a better place and put it
smiling and and shine joy to the world
yeah even though you're dealing
sometimes with hard issues like I do
yeah so let's get to that part because
that's the best part of you that I know
as the public person is this exuberant
person is passionate about what they do
and smiles and all this stuff making up
for lost time yeah yeah all right that's
that's great though that's what it's all
about right so when did you come to
America and how quickly did you realize
how great things are here it seemed even
right now when I say that things are
great here I always know there's a
certain amount of people in America that
how we say what is being just a blind
Patriot saying things you're great in
America but if someone that lives
through some [ __ ] yeah can you say
things are great here oh my god
America is God's gift to the universe
there is no place better than America
actually I ended up moving to Israel not
to America I ended up living in Israel
from 1984 to 1989
well I somehow I this that part device
how did you get to read my story I've
got a book title because they hate for
those of us for people are watching us
right now they can get the book and read
my story it's my memoir because I hate
fantastic it's a great encouraging story
about the tribe of the human spirit so
after we came out of the bomb shelter
when Israel invaded Lebanon my mother
became wounded we ended up going to an
Israeli hospital where I spent 22 days
with her and those things changed my
life it made me realize Israelis were
completely different than anything I
heard about and I vowed that one day I
will go back to this will and I end up
moving to Israel in 1984 and becoming a
news anchor for world news in the Middle
East in the 80s covering world events
are reporting and world events and and
actually you know as I reported in world
events I started realizing there was a
pattern developing because no matter
where the terrorist activity took place
the name of the perpetrators were always
Muslims Ahmed Mohamed Hussein Ali the
name of the victims were always
Westerners Christians and Jews Terry
when Terry Anderson Colonel Reagan's
Achille Lauro the TWA flight I can go on
and on and I started realizing that what
I used to think was a regional problem
where a majority Muslim middle east
trying to kill or expel the minority
Christians and Jews had become a
worldwide problem but the world was not
paying attention anyway from Israel I
met an American war correspondent and we
fell in love and we got married and
that's how I left Israel and came to
America and I came to the United States
in 1989 yeah so you get to the United
States I get to America and even though
you had been living in a democracy now I
know that for a couple years it's a
completely different democracy and a
plurality of people we have here and all
of that stuff the opportunity in America
is incredible it's incredible we came
here and we started our own business a
TV production company so I remember when
we were starting our own business he
went to the Chamber of Commerce
and there's score which is retired
executives who actually consult with you
on how to discuss your own business and
I remember going there and you can sit
with them and these are retired CEOs who
would advise you who will mentor you on
edges on you start your own business
this is what you need to do this is the
capital you need to read and they would
literally hold your hand then the
Chamber of Commerce had brochures and
I'm never looking at my ex-husband and I
remember looking at him and saying read
for free I yell to start your business
yeah
and I started learning about America and
how it operates the opportunities in
America you can be anyone you want to be
the sky is the limit there is no excuse
yeah
none whatsoever even today even those
who are coming here today to this
country yeah that the opportunities are
limitless it's incredible but I thought
were an evil patriarchal racist society
that's bent on white supremacy or
something am i absolute baloney listen I
came to this country in 1989 yeah and I
had my own TV production company I
worked so many jobs you know I I have
never felt as a second-class citizen or
persecuted or that I am different in any
way shape or form whatsoever
yeah America is an amazing place America
is a land if there was ever a place
where anyone can belong it's America
because we came here from everywhere and
everybody from all walks of life whether
your father was a janitor your father
was a mega millionaire you come to
America and you have a fresh start fresh
identity nobody cares what your father's
title is it's what you make of yourself
and you can be anything you want to be
mr. America it's amazing yeah fortunate
to live here yeah I lived in New York
City most of my life and when I go back
now every time I go on the subway I just
look around for a second and you quite
literally see everybody at the shade
color religion ethnicity nationality and
even if we're not all constantly full
fawning over each other we live together
just that in and of itself is an
incredibly beautiful
as someone that comes from a place that
unfortunately saw the reverse of it yeah
America is different and I can tell you
I was in Europe I go to Europe and so
three years ago I put my children on the
cruise in Europe and we went and it
closed around and everything and we
missed so much coming to America you
know what we miss the most being able to
have the variety of food that we have in
America all in one Street you walk down
one Street in America you can go one
night eat Chinese one night II Japanese
when I eat Lebanese when I eat Italian
yeah I mean one night eat die yeah the
variety America is so rich and culture
that truly melted into one pot isn't
very different than anywhere else in the
world so it's not cultural appropriation
when I eat Chipotle that's supposed to
be that way I'm telling you this is
insane America is an amazing place to
live and to thrive and anybody can come
here and thrive
[Music]
you
[Music]